Stunting is the result of chronic malnutrition.
So a child might be eating,...
...but not necessarily getting the complexity of nutrients...
...that you need to grow well.
One in four children under five in South Africa are stunted.
Stunting undermines the physical and the cognitive development of a child,...
....and it's almost completely preventable.
The brain is developing in the first trimester...
...and your baby is starting to move.
Grow Great was created...
...in response to the high levels of stunting in South Africa.
So the critical time is pregnancy.
Flourish is a mum and baby groups...
...that seeks to support, celebrate and empower new and pregnant moms...
...through the critical first thousand days,...
...and Champions for Children are community health care workers...
...providing households with intervention...
...that support maternal and child health nutrition.
We are denying ourselves the promise of this precious human capital...
...by not preventing stunting.